you
alright so hey everyone I'm no we're
going to talk about building
personalized and experiences through
iterations so iteration from the tech
back-end side all the way to testing and
iterative product development closing
the loop and I'll start off with two
scenarios so first imagine that your
Ryan really kind of in a groove and an
ad comes on that is maybe totally
irrelevant to your experience it really
throws off your remove this is
definitely happen to me it's probably
happen to you as well that's a terrible
experience that that sucks second
scenario imagine it you're you're
working you're studying and listening to
classical music something like that and
you get a loud rapid or allow rock at
that's that's also a terrible user
experience so pitch a kind work to
improve the free tier here at spotify
the preachers ad-supported but we don't
want the ass to be contrary to your
music experience music is something that
you carry with you throughout the day
it's something that you kind of match
with your mood you match with your
activity it's something that's really
personal and spotify is trying to build
a personal music product we've radio
that's personalized to your taste
personal most what you listen to we have
this browse section that's filled with
custom tailored playlist that was
supposed to go along with remember to go
along with your activity our view is
that your day with music books like this
it looks really varied and you're using
music for different reasons and kind of
utilitarian way throughout the day match
Jimmy match your mood while you're at it
like look like this why are they
monogamous like this so it's 55 we serve
a couple different kinds of ads we serve
music ads which we call the label labs
which could be promoting the latest
electronic music album we also serve
commercial ads for brands so say we're
serving an electronic music app
throughout the day you're hearing it no
matter what you're doing sometimes we
might get the experience right if you're
working out in the morning that's not a
bad experience if you're trying to study
or you're trying to focus at work that's
that's a terrible experience so that's
the problem that we're trying to solve
here on the personalization team and we
hear this kind of thing from users all
the time like we have a screen up with
Twitter and Facebook streaming in when
we're watching people talking about this
Spotify ads are really killing my mood
with all of this tech can she figure out
a better way to match my music and my
ads would be totally hear you these
people deserve a better user experience
than the one with again here are a few
more quotes I hate pop music why am i
hearing probably as it gets I hate rap
why I'm hearing rapids listen to
something else these people deserve a
better user experience and the one that
their game and we don't just hear this
from users we also see it empirically in
the data so this is a graph of the
distance between the genre of music that
users listening to at any one given
moment in a genre a music add that they
were served not going right so as we
move further for the left the distance
is further away from Berlin to the right
distance its closure between
between the adhan music and we see click
your aid in green here and then the
number of AD impressions that were
serving in blue if that won't make sense
so we see as the distance gets better as
the ad and the music that the users is
going to get closer the click-through
rate increase it's like that's something
that we cannot tonight we are definitely
improving user experience if we make
that distance smaller but we also know
that most of the time we're serving a
moderate to maybe even negative ads
experience like we're not in place where
we want to be so this is a clear
opportunity to improve the product
here's another example of just incorrect
data this is from a survey that we put
out a couple of months ago where we ask
people when our ads MOS disrupted when
rounds most annoying and we see during a
romantic moment partying with friends
you know when I'm with other people or
what I'm trying to focus that's when I
don't wanna be hearing ads ads are so
bad and less destructive one on
commuting or when I'm waking up in the
morning so this shows us another clear
opportunity to improve the user
experience and then finally this is the
result of a k-means clustering analysis
that we did own a bunch of features
related to how people use Spotify during
individual session right so we see some
clear sessions is we're indicating the
people are using Spotify they're using a
music differently in different
situations here on the top left for
instance you can see forty percent of
our sessions are short sessions where
the user is looking at the phone a lot
at the very beginning that's what these
blue bars represent
focus of the iOS app they're looking at
the apple lot in the beginning and the
app in their pocket and maybe they're
running or working or whatever they're
not looking at this modified anymore so
we know that people are using spa
defying all of these different ways and
we're trying to custom tailor our music
products to these people we're trying to
respect the modes that they're in we
should be doing the same thing with our
problems so that's that's the problem
I'll turn it over to kitchen to talk
about so as we will explain you know we
found a lot of user pain points few
months ago both through anecdotal
evidence through data backing some of
those pain points so we formed a team to
tackle some of these problems few months
ago and when you started off we knew
their bunch of different pain points and
we want to come up with a framework to
solve these different product problems
in a very sort of systematic way so that
we're not investing a lot of time and
energy building things which probably
would add your value so barring the
ideas from in a Lean Startup principle
it'll be followed this very agile
philosophy of figuring out different
user pinpoints you know which would be
the user stories and then coming up with
hypotheses different kinds of hypotheses
and booths to see whether we can build
products and validate those hypotheses
so we work in this constant loop of you
know constantly discovering different
pain points through data through a user
feedback which get converted into
hypothesis then we typically do not get
a build like a very extensive or rather
start on a very extensive project we
stop trying many more products and one
a/b tests to make sure that the
hypothesis is validated there's actually
value in building those products going
forward and we keep iterating up there
so to give you an example of what that
means so if you saw some of those tweets
are here and some of the data points now
offer users complain about as being too
non-relevant a good musical context so
for instance someone is streaming
classical music and then to get an ad
for a rap artist promotion which does
not make a lot of sense you know ideally
if you're listening to classical music
and there's music promotion for an album
which is for classical music that were
elevated so that was one of the
hypotheses something else you know
another example is users typically want
ads musical promotions to be targeted to
the taste profile so for instance is
directly if I listen to a lot of jazz
music you know I wouldn't probably enjoy
an artist promotion for an artist to
place a lot of metal so you know these
are the examples of some of the
hypotheses we come up with and once we
have these hypotheses as a product team
product and engineering team to sit down
a transfer or what are the products that
we need to build tube allocate these
hypotheses so for the first example of
context of our ads we figure out that
you know our app targeting based on the
musical context or the general context
of a user is broken and to fix that we
need to build an act auditing system
which can deliver ads which are really
relevant to the real time genre context
of a user similarly for taste profiles
we need to also process you users
historical genre preferences as I so on
and so forth so once we identify these
are the products that need to be built
to validate the hypothesis we do
standard AP tests the control group
couple of variations to see if the
hypothesis is actually true so having
come up with like this nice agile way of
you know Duke evolving the products
iteratively other challenge that most
people in product engineering teams face
and I'm sure if you have faced this
problem is how do you keep up your
infrastructure with these changing
product requirements you know today
you're starting to build on something
and by the time you actually done
finished building those systems the
requirements might have changed and in
our experience what worked really well
was having a good high level overview of
what one achieve and then we kept
trading on the infrastructure to keep up
to the product requirements so when you
started our kid we had a good believe
that going with the micro services
architecture where there is isolation of
concern would help us in a build and to
all systems independently of each other
at the same time we can make text tech
choices based on the requirements of the
product that we're going to build said
the higher at a very high level this is
what you know the envisions we will have
an ad server which exclusively focuses
on delivering ads and you know has bunch
of standard ad serving features like
pacing of an ad so that it delivers over
you know fixed rate of time evenly it
has blue management features bill again
but it wasn't necessarily going to focus
on the requirements of targeting an ad
to a user so we had a different service
which exclusively focused on coming up
with new targeting features and that
services backed by a user attributes
tour which would keep getting you know
incrementing new kinds of his
retribution which we could target pads
and to complete the feedback blue we
needed a good law collection system good
luck processing system which were
actually
help us process these events that
contributed by users and if you look at
this architecture debris high level if
you look at the components of the lower
half most of those things are standard
packet services that many companies ago
we will do and most of that was built up
top of in-house sort of back-end
infrastructure that we have and
propriety of reasons you know we have
like an in-house protocol that we use
for communication between packet
services so we ended up using but of
in-house technologies for building that
back-end infrastructure for this
specific top what would probably be more
exciting and relevant do you guys would
be you know the the components in the
upper half which are you know the data
infrastructure components that you've
used in architecture so some of the box
of that I'm going to fill in are going
to be law collection lock processing and
the storage system that used for storing
user profiles so going back to our
product equation you know the first
hypothesis that we have was to the
product for delivering context of
errands for that we have to build
earlier that coordinate system which
could deliver genre targeted ads so
before I dive deeper into the deck
choices that you made for filling in
these boxes the lock collection
processing data storage what I'm going
to do is I'm going to run you through a
quick evolution of our you know tech
stack as we be a different tech choices
over a period of time the satisfy our
product needs once i'm done with that
that means i'll be diving deeper into
the specific reasons of choosing these
technologies so the wee one when we were
trying to actually solve the problem for
you
targeting we started off by using Kafka
for a long processing sorry love
direction we you start kwacha storm for
love processing and use memcache because
it was really easy to set up and store
you know basic targeting p value
parameters for the storage of user
profile so once this basic product MVP
was built we started running experiments
to evaluate the hypothesis that there is
really value in building context or your
hands in the meantime why our
experiments were running you know we in
parallel started working on the next
type of this is so we are interesting
any time while we kept working on the
product iteration we started in parallel
evolving our tech infrastructure as well
so the second hypothesis was you know
let's make sure that the ads are
targeted based on you know a story to
musical preferences of a user their base
profiles for that what was necessary was
a batch computation of historical log so
we wanted to analyze users logs from
weeks and months before so we needed a
batch targeting you know rather batch
processing framework for all our loads
and for that we end up choosing apache
crunch so at this point in time while we
were still evaluating the first
hypothesis wadded up completing we
finished building up the second equation
of our architecture where we had sort of
the lab d'architecture where we are
processing 03 of time and batch a loss
and activity user profiles and the
storage was still remember cash at this
point in time and we call this version
2.5 because we we were sort of in the
middle of analysis of our hypothesis so
our experiment for context of our ads
by the time we found real value upon
engagement lift by actually targeting
the ads based on users context so we saw
that there is definitely value in
continuing to build this product and
with our current storage a sort of
solution we did a bunch of nice
properties that you would want with some
kind of storage within that persistence
you didn't have like a rich schema that
you could use for bunch of other
operations so we thought since we want
to improve our current infrastructure
make it more scalable we started
considering in a bunch of other no
sequel storage options and settle for
Cassandra for storing these user
profiles if you look at the this diagram
and this point in time you're still
reading the user attributes from
memcache but we are actually writing
these attributes go to web caching
Cassandra so why you were in this phase
what we were essentially doing was
benchmarking the Cassandra's we didn't
see because you know get concerns about
that and actually evaluating with that
technology for this problem and by the
time you'd actually done the
benchmarking we were happy with the
results we eventually transitioned over
to the center completely or the weights
in the rights were knocking from
Cassandra and this is our current you
know version 3.0 for the targeting
architecture looks like so you know
hopefully by sort of looking at this
evolution you've seen that how we've
managed to keep it waiting on an
architecture and product at the same
time we're not necessarily blocking one
of the other and we didn't have to you
know stall any of the operations which
continue working creatively so let me
not die a bit deeper into the choices
that can wait for each of these
technologies so let's start with lock
direction so today we've chosen calf
carpaccio kafka forelock direction for
those of you not work with gaffer before
if you go to their introduction page
this is how they describe themselves
it's a distributed partition
Tom o'clock service the way I think
about it is so distributed message to
you with some nice features like observe
it has some nice correcting is like
fault tolerance and in order message
delivery in the partition and the reason
we ended up choosing this or some of the
other solutions was that over the past
two or three years it is 45 as a whole
has tried different lock production /
solutions we've tried a patch it through
we've tried some homegrown solutions yep
tried Kafka in the meantime Kafka has
evolved as well it has become a bit more
mature and based on requirements
specifically for this problem where we
wanted process logs boot in real time
and in batch mode sort of Kafka's fit
the bill we have one of in-house
expertise and calf / we didn't want to
use a solution which is different from
what we use for regular la collection
and you know for rest of the stuff its
qualify so Kafka seem like a very
obvious choice and we settle with it so
in this diagram if you look yeah the
first box to log collection you know we
settle for Kafka and we know that it's
been supported within Spotify so that
end up being our choice in this
architecture of the v1 architecture the
choice for Allah processing framework
was a patchy storm again for those of
you who not work with the batches long
before it's like a you know it's a real
time stream processing framework it's
almost like mapreduce it's a lot of
reduce steps has some nice to entities
for fault tolerance and message delivery
and in the nice thing about storm is
that all that's still a bit immature and
it's still at version 0.9 point2 but
it's far more mature than some of its
competitors so while you know evaluating
this solution we saw what's its current
you say it was support by the community
and it's being tested at scale a Twitter
its competitors like Apaches
our spark spark streaming or celebrating
mature and do not give us the kind of
guarantees in Clayton see that we
require for some of our real time
problems so I purchased on seemed like a
good solution we've been working with it
for over six to seven months so far
we've been happy with the performance
and the nice thing quad it is that as
very engaged in active community
supporting it so since version 0.8 point
one test some nice you know testing
support built-in for those who've not
use storm before you know there are
concepts of bowls and spouts which are
essentially processing units which which
can do bunch of operations like
filtration aggregation joints etc and
the way you acquire them up is called a
topology so you know it's very easy to
test these typologies is overly without
actually applying them to a cluster just
really nice you can write strong jobs in
both GF non-gm languages we push through
the Java so it's pretty easy to write
unit tests and since the latest version
of there is a nice visualization support
as well you can see these typologies out
the end up looking under dashboard
that's really easy to understand how the
message is flowing through through your
graph for the next sort of tech choice
which we made which muscle for batch
clock messaging framework was an
interesting choice for a long time to
Spotify is probably if I'm still right
the big as the biggest hurdle cluster in
Europe and for the longest time via
using you know python MapReduce Python
streaming MapReduce for computing data
but over a period of time started
realizing a lot of pain points with that
as a company if you settle for using
apache
most of you know MapReduce computations
the nice thing about apache crunches
that you are not necessarily him with
very low level map and reduce operations
are dealing with high limit constraints
like filtering join etc so for those of
you work a lot with high and I have
secret like experience and it's easier
to bring the transition writing these
bad jobs little bit open for what Apache
crunch and it has some nice data
structures the lowest data containing
abstraction is something to call the
speed collection which is an immutable
collection of all the entries of like
teeth which he can be a kind of data set
and then you can do a bunch of
interesting operations like map and
combine it cetera so without going to
the details about a patch of crunch what
I would say were some standard features
that made us choose crunch over rather
standard by the extremum MapReduce was
the ease of testing it and really good
performance the benchmark diamond found
like five times a bit of five times very
performance as compared to similar
language jobs in Python swimming and
some of the nice things are like type
safety and support for higher level
operations which the pythons during that
doesn't have it also has they were
good support for our equals which we use
internally and if you look at this you
know sample job you clean like redo
these ten lines you can figure out
what's the gist of the whole operation
you can write just you know custom
filter operations and utility methods
but if you want to just understand what
the job is actually doing its it's not
that girl goes it has good testing
futures
that he would write for it so at this
point in time you know we had made
choices for both batch and real-time
clock processing frameworks and we were
thinking about coming up with a more
persistent data storage for storing a
real for storing our user profiles so
earlier we started off using memcache
because it was really easy to set up it
was simple key value store we could just
told read and write really fast set some
details and that work really well
invasion use case not so much in the use
case where we act actually stored in
over longer time so we get more
persistence between Richards schema to
sort of you know work on complex news
cases which probably became of the
difficult in memcache but our only
concern was that the wheels would you
produce door ruff doing some
benchmarking form that the weeds are not
that bad or even for the real time use
case so we ended up choosing Cassandra
over memcached now all the new secret
solutions the reason we chose Cassandra
specifically was that again it's it has
an active community the project itself
is maturing and specifically at spotify
develop in-house expertise in the center
and use it quite a lot in other products
as well so it was sort of a natural
choice so today this is our system looks
it has a wall and hopefully gave you
some insight about how
building coming up place like a higher
level vision of how the architecture
should ve over the the boxes with
different technology stacks and you know
if you were to zoom out of this embed
flow of the events in our system to play
a look like this so we have all the logs
going through Kafka get stored in HDFS
for batch computation Kafka streams
those logs to storm and start and crunch
respectively process things love
messages in reliving badge and then
eventually the user profiles are updated
in Cassandra where all the weeds happen
from the actor billing service for
serving personalized ads so now is going
to talk us through the rest of the part
about how to actually in the testing
these features once we build
alright so that's iteration in the tech
back-end i'm going to talk quickly about
iteration excuse me in testing quickly
back to this so our flow here is we
start with our user stories the problems
that we see in our user base we go from
there and a hypotheses and goals we
build product and VPS with this little
engineering effort as possible so that
we can glue back and learn in every
cycle through here should end with a
test if we're not testing and learning
we have failed basically but the very
first kind of test that we can run test
phase zero if you will is before we
build anything just looking at the data
that we have so I'll come back to these
two graphs and what they told us about
users and their experience with that and
what they told us about what we might
build this gave us the direction to then
begin actually building before we put in
any engineering effort before we even
started on our product MVP or started to
finding our product MVP so from that
phase zero we go to moving through this
as quickly as possible and that takes
the form of a be testing so an example
of an a/b test we might run we ran
recently is surveying a wrap add two
people who are listening to rap first
people who are listening to something
completely different or surveying add
that is study oriented to one of our
focus playlists or serving against a
playlist that's completely unrelated to
studying those are the kinds of AP tests
that we run once we get into this loop
so when we're running our a/b tests how
do we define what success like how do we
evaluate our results well logic will
tell you that if you can't move your top
level metrics you can't move metrics
like how long are people staying on the
service or are people upgrading or not
we call these our AAA our metrics
acquisition activation and retention
if we can't move a are like why are we
building stuff why why do we continue
testing we found though that these
higher level metrics are really hard to
move and it's even hard to move metrics
one teardown so we define once you're
down as being our vital signs metrics
these are metrics like how long did
somebody use Spotify during the day how
many streams to big listen to during the
day we've even found that that it's hard
to move in a lot of areas and that's not
just adds it's all across the company
and I'm sure you've seen similar stuff a
lot of movement happens kind of down
fear in your lowest level metrics for us
that's our ad specific metrics so if we
can't move this top-level stuff is it
worth continuing to test and our answer
is is yeah it is as long as you can see
constant improvement in user experience
over time so this is kind of how we
conceptualize this there is a threshold
of user experience at which you will
impact your top level metrics there's a
threshold at which you will actually
cause people to stay on Spotify or your
service or leave or upgrade whatever it
is but that threshold is obscured by any
number of factors for us it's people
liking Spotify in general having pretty
high tolerance so if I'm a user and I
like talking with my friends on Spotify
sharing music creating playlists I'm not
going to notice or care so much about
what the ads experience is like even if
we make it 5x better but at a certain
point we will actually begin to to
attack that so that's why our focus at
least right now is on ads
centers if any sense and then diving
into what those metrics look like
because we're so focused on user
experience we don't just look at the
upside of advertising like you might
kind of think if you're looking at
analyzing the impact of a banner ad or
an audio ad we look at positive and
negative signals for us it's important
to see whether people are responding to
the ads but also whether people are
annoying by the ads and trying to avoid
them we need to balance that out so for
us positive signals are signals life of
course click through rate we can also
see downstream effects like if we if we
promoted an album do people actually go
in to listen to that album three days
later those are the kinds of things that
we measure and try to look at that's
positive on the negative side we know
from surveying users and from looking at
data that volume for us is somewhat of
an annoyance meter if people don't like
the ad lay low the volume have this
experience so we look at volume changes
we look at audio output two people to
users unplug the headphones right that
kind of thing which is a pretty strong
signal and eventually we're hoping to
roll all of these into a series of that
quality scores using a classification
algorithm where we can say you know this
ad or the sad experience was X percent
annoying or X percent positive and
compared to all of our other ad
experiences so that's how we evaluate
tests and is all we have for you so
thank you so much we're hiring if you
want to work on these problems order
something similar and let's take some
questions
from the BB add volume on this
are you limited to just you know in the
actual application itself to being able
or is it
so I actually
yeah okay so question is how limited our
weight in measuring volume changes the
answer that is it's totally dependent on
the client so on iOS it's different than
Android which is different than desktop
we have more or less freedom depending
on the client and one of the really
interesting things about working on the
ants team is we were across all the
clients and we do have to kind of
generalize our metrics across all of
those different kind of back-end
infrastructures so it depends
right so in that case that so the
question is for that for that graph
where we showed similarity between the
ads and the music of usually this was
listening to how do we determine
distance if it's now music add that
graph was just for music adds I think
that eventually we can probably get to
replace what we're saying you know if
you're listening to or maybe if you're
running you here in ikea that's a that's
a close similarity and something else is
far away but we're not
so what kind of difference can we see
between the best experiences and worse
in terms of click-through rate I'd say
you saw the whole range there at graph
from the WTF which is near zero I mean
unfortunately I can't talk about actual
clip to rights but up to 10 20 acts when
you go to the best bad experiences I
mean we think about music ads if we just
focus on that in their very best place
it's being kind of like content kind of
like music recommendations and we're
seeking to build an infrastructure
that's similar to our music
recommendation constructor for ads but
they feel personal and like something
that you would like to attention yes
okay so the question is who would like
to go move bit more of our star cluster
so right now we have a cluster pretty
small cluster actually which which which
we are running on six hosts and it's a
very catered spawn cluster we already
just want apologies were targeting and
as I side the diagram point awhile ago
you know this is roughly how to polish
your lips neck so we have a bunch of you
know pasts which could be either spouts
of bowls processing the two kinds of
things and on an average I cannot speak
about volume of events that we see but
you know on average we see hundreds of
thousands of events per second and we
are running 01 night went to ubuntu is
is that it or you want more information
because we can we take care of excessive
specifics yeah
what are you using to read from kefka
youre talking about this diagram is
particular so I specifically don't knows
we have like a dedicated infrastructure
Scott working on a direction which
focuses on that part of the pipeline for
some of riding calf Exodus to HDFS so
unfortunately I don't know the specifics
of those but I can find that out and we
can discuss later
so the question is are we being pretty
targeting were turning in real time if I
understand your question correctly are
you asking like do we tag users as you
know in tenders for certain kind of adds
advance for no so the way it works is
like we assign users with different tags
so we you know some of the tax with the
basic customer regular taxi like
demographic tags like gender etc and
then some of them cardboard custom tags
life and add as as high affinity to
classical music for instance those kind
of things and the assignment of tides
happen both in real time and in batch
mode so in this diagram the storm
pipeline generates the stacks per user
in real time whereas if you're doing any
kind of historical analysis those taxes
on time generation happens in some of
batch mode once those tags are assigned
and storing Cassandra the rule matching
happens in real time so the axe server
when it makes a call to act auditing
service says like give me all the
relevant touch with the user the I
targeting service does some some kind of
filtration and sort of declaration of
responses but its nuclear eating from
this data store an ad server does the
room management for attaching it says
okay I have all these ads targeted to
users who should be listening classical
music and these are other users could be
valued
music thanks so then it doesn't matter
so the users have sort of in that sense
prius underpants but the matching
happens in building
and sure yeah okay so we ran a previous
test where we served different add loads
and frequencies to users so we increase
the output a little bit for some users
we decrease you have a little bit other
users those differences to a long time
to actually manifest themselves in the
AAR metrics but we saw first people you
know talking about having that a
different ad experience a bad experience
or good at experience in our mps data
and on social media we picked that
signal up kind of first then we
definitely did see changes in the vital
signs metrics and number streams over
time and then click through rate and
then eventually after a few months we
saw changes in an AR metrics but they
took a while to show up and we would
have probably turned the test off if we
hadn't seen those those kind of primary
indications that we would see something
bigger in the future
did you say I was curious about the
attack
ok so the way so if I understand your
question correctly the question was how
do you determine what tags need to reply
to a user and what tags need to be
applied to that with this wind and I
Hardison an actor that basement so right
now the way it works is those
assignments are not necessarily done in
an automated way you know you would
manually go and assign certain things so
for instance if a firm for musical ads
it's all very obvious if you're doing an
artist promotion for an artist who plays
a lot of hip hop music it's easy to
assign that user that artist genre of
hip hop right so that's very obvious for
brands it's a bit more complicated so
some brands have a lot of insights about
what their audience is like so for
instance you know and I'm just making of
this example right now so don't take my
word for it for instance redbull might
say okay you know of our users or
individual users and they like the kind
of music which represents adventure and
then they might assign themselves genre
which would match with that the way to
start working future once you have a lot
of data because right now it's a cool
start remembering these features we
don't have a lot of insights about these
brands what works for them what does it
work for them in the future once you
have not more data we can analyze what
are the relevant tags for different
types of it work I do the brands and
advertisers what works for them what
gives them in a lift and engagement and
then we can start problematically
viewing and changing these things in
real time as opposed to ecstatically if
I mean
one of the I guess benefits that you
guys have is that we have
user login as opposed to a cookie ID a
player you're not guessing can actually
see changes what are the kind of thing
to do as far as across device
I can install chain changes in so the
question is what kinds of differences do
we see cross-platform because we can
track the user from their iphone to
their desktop but what kind of changes
are you kind of thinking is there like
those poor performance like is there
generally higher CTR yeah so we
definitely do see a difference in CTR
across all of our platform that has to
do with the ad placement on the
platforms which makes testing kind of
tricky if differences between the
products are manifesting themselves in
your test results it's something you
need to think about the attention to try
to normalize out but yes we definitely
do see differences and something we need
to take into account
regularly
yeah that's an interest okay so do we
segment the customers when we're doing
the users when we're doing a be testing
do we say let these people are really
time or under that so we're going to
watch them and these people are very
tolerant at all so we're going to watch
them as well that's that's a tricky one
I mean it's something that you always
need to kind of need to walk the line
carefully because if you segment to
finally you'll always find a segment
that shows what you want to see or or
doesn't show what you don't want to see
but at the same time you want to make
sure you're getting full the full
picture I think I I'd say we try to we
try to be general because we do want to
know that the changes that we're making
are going to make a meaningful impact
across the entire user base but we do do
moderate segmentation we do segmentation
my country for sure segmentation by age
segmentation by platform is a really
interesting one I don't really like to
go more finely grained than that just
because you do get so far down that
you'll find a difference but it won't
actually be meaningfully me to balance
what's meaningful with what's detectable
if that makes sense
yeah that is interesting we ran a test
with 16 segments and that seemed to be
kind of the upper bound of what we could
meaningfully kind of analyze
okay thanks well thank you so much